[Music]
what if you had the power to control
things without touching them what if you
could use your mind for anything from
bending spoons to lifting cars even
stopping bullets right in front of you
what would be the limit to what your
brain could do this is what if and
here's what would happen if telekinesis
was real since the early days of
spiritualism psychic mediums have
claimed to contact the dead during these
sessions their clients could see objects
mysteriously flying across the room many
people believed what they saw only they
didn't see the hidden wires that the
mediums used to fool their audience
telekinesis also called psychokinesis
has been debunked by skeptics like Harry
Houdini in 1926 the magician offered
$10,000 to anyone who could showcase
psychic abilities that he couldn't mimic
on stage nobody left Houdini's show with
the prize in the 1970s telekinesis
caught the attention of the US and
Soviet governments they spent decades
running tests but the only thing they
could prove is that telekinesis is
nothing more than entertainment for the
masses but imagine what you could do if
you had a power like that how would you
use it let's start with this telekinesis
wouldn't be limitless think of it as an
invisible set of muscles the more you
trained your telekinetic muscles the
stronger you'd get maybe you could
handle bringing a remote control over to
the couch maybe you could make yourself
a cup of tea without having to go to the
kitchen or you might make small things
levitate just for fun
once you got good at all that you could
start practicing with something bigger
like moving cars around in a parking lot
this would tire you out pretty fast and
might not happen on the first try
because just like any work out
practicing telekinesis wouldn't be easy
you'd need to keep working on it maybe
you could master your telekinetic
ability enough to push clouds away and
save your city from a hurricane or a
tornado making yourself fly through the
air would be harder
that would require you to push yourself
away from the objects around you it
would only work for short distances but
it could come in handy during rush hour
it would really be up to you how you'd
use your powers but forget about lifting
an entire building into the air I can't
say exactly where your limit would be
but elevating something that's much
bigger and heavier than you are would
certainly be over that limit using your
telekinetic powers could easily get out
of control and become dangerous to
everyone around you most likely it would
require a lot of time and willpower to
do even the easiest tricks maybe it's a
good thing that none of that could
actually be done in the real world the
laws of physics dictate that brain waves
can't travel beyond the confines of your
skull you can't bend metal with your
mind make things fly and you certainly
can't levitate yourself but what if
there was a way to give you at least a
tiny bit of this superpower performing
telekinesis could be real but it would
include implanting small wires into your
brain
technology is already able to read your
mind by using an implant that translates
brain activity into speech now
companies like para drama send Elon
Musk's neural link are working on tech
that could let you move objects just by
thinking about them their research is
meant to help patients suffering from
paralysis blindness or locked-in
syndrome and it could change lives
forever
people who suffer from paralysis could
use a brain implant to control computer
devices and artificial limbs eventually
the implants could be as common as
cellphones
a device in the brain would transfer
high volumes of data through threads
much much thinner than a human hair it
wouldn't be the kind of telekinesis you
see in the movies instead it would be a
tech assisted one and what if that would
be the beginning of us merging with our
technology what if the next step
involves becoming full cyborgs well
that's a story for another what if
you